YUFENG GUO: Previously
on AI Adventures,
we looked at how to use feature
activations for understanding
neural networks.
How can we extend these ideas
further and get even more out
of these methods?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to AI Adventures where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to extend
the ideas of feature activations
in convolutional neural
networks even further by
applying them to entire images
to create activation
grids and then see
how we can use that to
produce an activation atlas.
This video picks up where
the previous video left off.
So if you haven't watched
that, you should definitely
check it out first.
Now previously, we
looked at how the neurons
in a convolutional
neural networks layers
can be organized into
channels and then stacked
like a layer cake.
We can also organize it
in our mind vertically
so that we are looking at a
certain patch of that layer
and consider the activation of
all neurons stacked together
over a region.
We call this
spatial activations.
Spatial activations
give us a sense
of what features a
specific region of an image
is activating most strongly.
By doing this across all the
different patches of an image,
we can build an activation
grid, showing us
the features that are activating
the strongest for each region.
This is for only one
particular layer.
So now we want to repeat this
process for the other layers--
some earlier in the
network and some later.
Earlier layers,
like mixed 3a, they
show us the edges and patterns
that still mildly resemble
the original image,
while later layers
are much more identifiable
as the animal body
parts that are being recognized
in that part of image.
Now, activations are--
they're just numbers, right?
And so some activations, they
can be larger than others.
So what we can now do is scale
the size of each of these grids
to the size of the activation.
So that'll give us a sense
of the importance of a given
region of the image to that
layer based on how strongly
the network is activating.
So now we can see which regions
are most strongly activated
per layer, and how these
activations are propagating
through each layer
of the network.
Now, this gives us a
sense of the saliency
of the different
parts of the image.
Activation grids
tell us about some
of the activations of the neural
network for a specific image.
But what about all the other
activations of the network?
How might we understand the
other types of activations?
Well, we'd need to
feed in lots of example
images of all sorts of types.
So what if we did that?
We could run lots of images.
In fact, we could run a million
different example images
through the network and record
all of their activation routes.
All these individual
activations correspond
to some kind of
higher-dimensional location
in the neural networks
activation space, so to speak.
And if we position
our activations, each
of these subgrids, into
their respective locations
in this
higher-dimensional space,
we now have for our
1 million example
images broken up and scattered
across this landscape.
Unfortunately,
high-dimensional spaces
are, well, they're tough
for us to visualize.
So we can project this space
down to two dimensions.
But there's still
the problem having
just millions of activations
that deal with array.
So that's rather
unwieldy for visualizing.
So let's draw a grid over
the whole 2D projection.
And we'll take for
each grid the average
of the activations within it.
This won't cause us to lose too
much detail since activations
that are close together,
they're similar to one another.
So now we can finally
resize each grid
based on a number of
activations on our grid,
giving us a sense of how
strongly the network responds
to that particular
type of input.
Now, we can repeat
this entire process
for a couple different
layers, put it
into a nice web interface, and
you have an activation atlas.
So let's explore
it and see what it
looks like to navigate
through this space.
If we start our journey in the
top area of the layer mixed 4c,
there appears to be kind
of a variety of dog faces.
Then as we go down, things
shift to showing how
the backs of
four-legged animals.
And then we keep going.
We get to some legs and
feet merging into the ground
and ground-related things.
And that slowly transitions
into kind of sandy services
and some water.
There's lots of interesting pats
through the activation atlas.
And it's really neat, I
think, that the images shown,
they smoothly transition
from one region to the next.
We can also look at a specific
class activations in the atlas
so we can filter it out and just
look at one particular class.
Let's say the great white shark.
I like to start with the
bottom-most layer, mixed 5b,
since that's going
to show images that
are most similar to kind
of the final prediction
so we can really
recognize what it is
we're seeing-- it's meaningful.
We see some regions
we'd expect--
various fish-like imagery.
And over here there's some
water-related imagery, right?
And what's this over here?
Yeah, is that a baseball?
What is a baseball doing so
late in the network structure?
So if the network thinks that
baseballs have a pretty strong
relationship to, well,
great white sharks,
what would happen then?
Perhaps if we added an
image of a baseball,
just slapped it on top of
this image of a gray whale,
could we fool our neural
network into thinking that it's
seeing a great white shark?
At first, it doesn't quite work.
But with a bit of fiddling
around with the image size,
we can get the network to
output great white shark
as its top prediction
for the image.
This is pretty fun.
And you can look for all
sorts of other oddities.
I also found in the mixed 5b
layer for a great white shark
that airship is another kind
of unusual label associated
with great white sharks.
So I tried to do
something similar.
I went online and found
some images of airships
and tinkered around with
the sizing and position
of the airship image.
And I found that I could
eventually convince the model
that it was a great white
or in some cases, a killer
whale, depending on the airship
I use and where I put it.
So you should try
this out and be
sure to share what kinds
of funny predictions
you got the model to make
in the comments down below.
Neural networks are
generally opaque.
But with tools like activation
atlas at your disposal,
you can get a
better understanding
of how they work and expose
some of the weaknesses that
might be present.
I'm excited about
the possibility
of how these approaches will be
extended in the future, as well
as its applications to other
types of models as well.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed
it, please like
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out
activation atlases
and see if you
can find something
interesting in the relationships
between the different data
classes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]